it is time now for CBS deals and this
morning we have items that could help
provide a little self-care for the
adults as well as some fun for the kids
and all an exclusive low prices to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit
cbsdeals.com
knocking Chief content officer Candy
Carter joins us with more good morning
and we sure have like the perfect like
late March activity here I am so excited
so first of all go to cbsdeals.com right
now because we want everybody shopping
with us okay solo wave this is one of
our most popular products solar wave is
a red light therapy heat wand it is the
number one Beauty tool at home beauty
tools celebrities they absolutely love
it and what does it do okay so it's red
light therapy so see that red light you
rub it on your skin and it helps with
wrinkles finally give it to me right
here right right in here dark spots
puffy eyes and it is it's It's a
Wonderful at home tool I got a facial it
was two hundred dollars yeah so you do
this under five minutes a day for three
days a week and it helps with wrinkles
fine lines and this is 99.99 it's under
a hundred dollars it's 33 off today so
solo wave we love it so excited about it
I am obsessed with this hey buddy hey
pal every single Easter my daughter's
like Mom I want to do Easter eggs I
never want to do it the little wire
things you're dipping it in you're
getting the dial over your it smells
like vinegar and it smells like vinegar
it's awful this is amazing look at how
gorgeous these eggs are it's super
simple so you just grab a marker okay
turn it on and you hold the marker down
can we do this there we are okay hold on
hold the marker okay and all you do look
at that it makes the most gorgeous
I used to look at Martha Stewart Living
to say I want my to look like hers now
they can do this here's the best part
it's 36 off it's only 17.99 it's under
20 dollars it's a no-brainer you can do
it with your kids grandparents like like
you all the grandparents oh can we do it
with kids they're coming yes I want to
do it for myself and decorate my house
but you can do it as a family now my
husband will do it because it's easy so
okay let's go on to this okay better not
younger this is fantastic this is for
aging hair thinning hair I notice on the
side I have thinning hair it's a super
simple applicator you pour the serums in
here we have it for if you have thinning
hair aging scalp or if you getting older
or if you just want to really
conditioner that thickens the hair
better not younger the founder is we're
celebrating women's History Month she
sold products in Corporate America and
decided she wanted to make a product
there she is some Salas Gonzalez she
wanted to make a product for women and
men over 50. you literally massage it
into your hair it's super simple see
she's putting it in there and it's 50
percent off feel that it's 50 off
between 28 and 42. incredible so
important we have dry hair when we get
older absolutely thanks so much thank
you Michelle of course we partner with
all of these companies get these deals
to buy anything you saw today just scan
that QR code on your screen or head on
over to cbsdeals.com